عن
اي تفسير اصدار هذه المذكره من قبل
الرقابه العسكريه الان لماذا الان وليس من
قبل بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك لضيفك
الكريم ولجمهور ايه الواقع بان دوله
الاحتلال بدات تدرك بان المعلومات في هذه
الحرب تخرج عن السيطره كان الاحتلال يراهن
من منذ اللحظات الاولى لهذه الحرب انه
سيصيب المقاومه بالصدمه والرعب لكن ما حدث
اولا من ثبات المراسلين في قطاع غزه
وتحديدا مراسلي م مراسلي الجزيره الذين
لهم كل التحيه الذين يعني فعلا او بشكل
فعلي ضحوا بانفسهم
وببيضة
كل ذلك خلق روايه مضاده للاحتلال هذه
الروايه يعني الاحتلال بدا يراها وهي
تتسرب لجمهوره بدا يراها وهي تتسرب للشارع
الاسرائيلي وكما قال ديفيد بن جوريون
عندما اسس هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ليس
المهم ما يقول العالم المهم ما يسمعه
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي اراد ارادت حكومه
الاحتلال ان يسمع مواطني الاحتلال الحقيقه
من طرف واحد وهي فقط الرقابه العسكريه
وبالتالي تم التشديد على كل ما يحدث في
هذه الحرب من يتابع اي استديو من
الاستديوهات التحليليه ربما يتابع ساعه
وساعتين لكن لا يخرج بكلمه مفيده واحده عن
سير المعارك الى اين تتجه الامور ما الذي
يريده الجيش ما الذي يحققه يعني ياخذون
اشياء تافهه وبسيطه مثل الادعاء على على
العث ثور على هويه او صوره هويه لمحمد
الضيف في بيت ما ويتحدثون عن ذلك لساعات
وساعات طويله ياخذون صوره غرض ما او شيء
ما كان يعود لاحد المقاومين ويتحدثون عن
ذلك ايضا لساعات طويله يعني حقيقه اصبح
متابعه الاعلام العبري يعني نوع من التلوث
السمعي والبصري لا تكاد تخرج باي صوره
واضحه عن سير المعارك القتلى ال المجريات
السياسيه او العسكريه اسال ذات السؤال
ضيفي من غزه الدكتور حسام الدجني لمحاوله
فهم لماذا هذه المذكره ومات وما تضمنته
هذه المذكره من بنود
وتفاصيل يعني في تقديري هذه المذكره هي
جاءت بعد تصريحات عديده ل باث على سبيل
المثال السفير الامريكي في اسرائيل السابق
مارتن اندك عندما قال ان نحن امام مرحله
تحول بات ما لا يقوله نتنياهو يقوله
الصحفيون الكبار هناك حاله سيوله في
المعلومات تتسرب بشكل مقصود من جزء من
المؤسسه العسكريه التي بالتاكيد باتت تؤمن
ان هذه الحرب هي لاهداف نتنياهو السياسيه
ي اليوم هناك مقال او يوم امس عفوا هناك
مقال للصحفي والخبير الامني والاستراتيجي
الذي تحدث بشكل يعني معمق حول وهو رونين
بريجمان حول موضوع لماذا تتحدث اسرائيل
الان عن صفقه تبادل هو يتحدث بشكل كبير ان
هناك ضغوط امريكيه باتت
يعني تتضح ملامحها وهذا حتى تقاطع مع
مقاله توماس فريدمان في مقاله في
النيويورك تايمز الذي قال انه اسقاط حماس
لا يمكن ان يتم وان تحرير الاسرى او
الرهائن لا يمكن ان يتم بالقوه هناك
قناعات بدات تترسخ تخلط اوراق نتنياهو جزء
منها انه هناك تسريبات اعلاميه بحجم
الخسائر الاسرائيليه بعيدا عن رغبه
نتنياهو واركان اداره الحرب لذلك اراد
نتنياهو ان يضبط الايقاع تحت طائله
المسؤوليه هذه الوثيقه ليست جديده في
اسرائيل متعارف عليه منذ سنوات لا يمكن
نشر اي شيء دون الرقيب العسكري ولكن عندما
تتابع اليوم هناك السوشيال ميديا ليس من
السهل ضبطها نحن ك كمتابعين نتابع صفحه
نتنياهو ونرى التعليقات على هذه الصفحه
على تويتر على اكس او على غيرها من
المنصات وبذلك في تقديري انه هذه الوثيقه
تعكس كم هو الواقع الصعب في داخل اسرائيل
وكم هو القلق على المجتمع الاسرائيلي بان
هناك انحرافات في لحظه الحرب هكذا يسمونها
لا في ظل زياده وتيره التظاهرات حول
الورقه الاقوى لدى المقاومه وهي ورقه
الاسرى والحرب النفسيه التي تحاول
المقاومه ان تضغط من اجل وقف اطلاق النار
ومن اجل ابرام سبق التبادل كل ذلك هي
عوامل ربما ساهمت في اطلاق هذه الوثيقه
فقط اشيل الخبر العاجل نقنع المراسل
الجزيره قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقتحم
بلده بيت
جنوب نابلس اعود الى ضيفي من نابلس عزام
ابو عدس ايضا في محاوله فهم وقراءه ما
تضمنته
هذه المذكره وتاثيرها على الشارع
الاسرائيلي وهنا اسال عما تعلق ببعض
التفاصيل ذات الشق العسكري مثلا بعض
البنود تحضر الحديث على نوع الاسلحه
المستعمله بعض الاماكن الحساسه التي قد
تستهدف الى ماذا يؤشر ذلك في الداخل
الاسرائيلي وهذه الحساسيه في التعامل مع
معطيات من هذا القبيل يفترض انها قد تكون
بالنسبه لجيش بحجم الجيش الاسرائيلي
معلومات عاديه وليس ولا يجب تظليلها او
التغطيه
عنها يعني في عرف الجيوش لا يوجد شيء اسمه
معلومه عاديه كل معلومه لها قيمتها اذا
استخدمت في المكان الصحيح وبعد الدخول الى
غزه وجمع المعلومات الاستخباراتيه من الا
الارض كما يقال تبين لجيش الاحتلال امران
مهمان الامر الاول بانه لم يكن يعلم عن
قطاع غزه الا شكل الا بشكل ضحل جدا ولا
ابالغ ان قلت قشور القشور وهذا ما تبين من
موضوع الانفاق من موضوع الحاله الصحيه
لمحمد الضيف والكثير من القضايا ايضا تبين
بان حركه حماس كانت تجمع معلومات بطريقه
استخباراتيه دقيقه جدا ومعمق عن دوله
الاحتلال من مختلف من مختلف المصادر سواء
كانت مصادر تجسس مباشر او غير مباشر تبين
من خلال مصادره بعض الوثائق والفيديوهات
والدخول الى بعض المقرات بان حماس اقامت
وحدات كانت تعمل على مدار الساعه ولسنوات
طوال برصد كل شيء يصدر عن الاعلام عن
الجيش ضباطه جنوده اسلحته مواقعه حتى
فيديوهات التيك توك التي كان يبثها الجنود
من قواعدهم العسكريه وهم يرقصون ويغنون
وما الى ذلك كانت تاخذها وتحللها ويعني
كانت تنظم هذه المعلومات بطريقه
استخباراتيه عميقه جدا هذا دفع جيش
الاحتلال الى محاوله حجب اكبر قدر ممكن من
المعلومات وبالتالي الاحتلال الان يحاول
ان يتدارك كل الخلل الامني الذي اصابه على
مدى سنوات طوال و ادى الى السابع من
اكتوبر وبالتالي ذهبت او ذهبت مع الريح
هيبه الجيش الاسرائيلي وا اجهزه
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه التي كانت يعني
يفترض بانها تعرف كل كبيره وصغيره في قطاع
غزه كما كانت تدعي وتبين في النهايه انها
لا تعرف الا معلومات ضحله جدا وفي بعض
الاحيان سربت لها معلومات عمدا لتبني صوره
خاطئه عن ما يدور داخل قطاع دكتور حسام
ايضا فيما يتعلق بهذه المذكره ولكن ما
تعلق منها بموضوع الاسرى والمحاذير وايضا
ما يضبط هذه المده او هذه هذا الموضوع في
هذه المذكره هل السبب الاساسي انه ربما
ادراك بان فصائل المقاومه تستفيد مما يثار
اعلاميا ام لحسابات في الداخل
الاسرائيلي هي بكليهما الاول بالتاكيد
هناك قراءه فيما يتعلق من موا واضح ان لدى
المقاومه الفلسطينيه عمق في موضوع الحرب
النفسيه
وفهم حقيقي لترتيبه المجتمع الاسرائيلي
يعلمون انه من الناحيه الدينيه حتى
المتدينين الاكثر تطرفا ضمن مبدا رمبام
يتحدثون انه يجب ان تدفع اسرائيل الفديه
من اجل الافراج عن اي اسير وبذلك القناعه
الراسخه لدى جميع المكون المجتمع
الاسرائيلي بضروره اعاده هؤلاء الى ذويهم
لا سيما ان العمليات العسكريه فشلت
والقتلى يتزايدون اكثر من 60 قتيل اصبح
نتيجه هذا القصف وهذا الاقتحامات وعمليات
الكوماندوز الفاشله بل على العكس قتل جنود
من الذين جاؤوا ليحرر كما حصل مع الجندي
صعر باروخ وبذلك انت امام نقطه تحول
المساله الثانيه هي مرتبطه بان المقاومه
من خلال ان من ابث المواد من قبل الاعلام
الاسرائيلي وهذا ما يخشاه نتنياهو
والحكومه الاسرائيليه من شانه ان يزيد من
حده التظاهرات ولكن لا يعني ما لا يعني
يؤمن به نتنياهو ان المجتمع الاسرائيلي
والقريه الصغيره التي يعني هي صفه العولمه
ان الان تصل المواد باي طريقه ممكن ان تصل
عبر متابعات على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
ولكن هو يحاول ان يقوض لا سما هو يحاول ان
يضبط ايقاع الصحفيين الاسرائيليين الذي
بات يعلو صوتهم كما قال اي السفير
الامريكي في اسرائيل السابق مارتن اندك
هذا الذي يخشاه لانه كنا نتابع اليوم هناك
مقال ايضا لن حمان شاي يتحدث عن عزله
اسرائيل ويتحدث عن موضوع صفقه التبادل
والكل بات ينادي بصفقه التبادل حتى
نتنياهو بات يتحدث عنها لانه لا يستطيع
تجاوزها ويحاول ان يقلل حجم الضغوط لانه
تفاعلات نهايه الحرب تقترب في تقدير يناير
حاسم جدا في موضوع نهايه الحرب لان فبراير
ستبدا الدعايه الانتخابيه في الولايات
المتحده وكل المؤشرات تربك حسابات بايدن
والديمقراطيين وبذلك سيكون الضغط الامريكي
هائل خلال شهر يناير وهذا ربما الذي يفسر
الحمله المسعوره التي ازدادت وسيرتها
ومحاوله تسويق اي صوره كانها انتصار مثل
زياره جلنت وجنس لغزه وكانه انتصار وبذلك
هو يريد ان يضبط ايقاع الحمله الاعلاميه
حتتى يحقق اكبر نتائج قبل ان يرضخ للضغوط
الامريكيه من غزه الدكتور حسام الدجني
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وكذلك الضيفي من
نابلس الباحث في الشان الاسرائيلي ع عزام
ابو العدس شكرا لكما